if someone would an all-knowing being
could come down to solve a mystery for
me
i would ask
is there any
particular point
to existence
that's a big that's uh well she said
anything yeah so you'd ask what why is
the life yeah i think and i would expect
they'd kind of say it was just a random
uh series of
events that caused
cells to
form together and and here we are now
that's what i would assume they'd say
don't overthink it but i'd like to know
and then these cells that came together
and became life
then don't want to die
yeah of course but why do they want you
what not downing
well cause if you're dead
there's nothing
but the cells will still exist would
they though i mean cells die surely no
well yeah well energy doesn't right but
cells do
but the the things that make up the
cells don't
what the electricity no the the quacks
and the quarks and the atoms and stuff
so here that's what i would ask
even more than life
why is there anything
right
good
i think we asked brian green that but he
wasn't 100 sure i don't think anyone has
if there's anyone out there that has a
specific
burning question
that you want to try and
get answered and maybe billy and i could
answer it yeah but if if anyone has the
answers to
life the universe and everything
you'll give us that oh
[Music]
the baby you're my
[Music]
you